okay i i do want to get to something a
little more substantive we continue to
see this debate over statues and
monuments and statues are getting pulled
down when they are uh sometimes
confederate statues or whatever the case
may be and we have another example of
that in virginia in richmond virginia um
a robert e lee statue has been removed
robert e lee a big confederate general
essentially a traitor it was robert e
lee was a guy
fighting against the union aka the
united states at the time
for the right to continue owning slaves
he was a pro-slavery trader to the
united states is the way that i would
put it
robert e lee statue was taken down in
richmond virginia and donald trump put
out a statement saying that the statue
was magnificent and robert e lee was a
genius
what i mean it it's beyond words it's
beyond words let's take a look at the
statement this put out through the save
america pack of president donald j trump
uh trump says
just watched as a massive crane took
down the magnificent and very famous
statue of robert e lee on his horse in
richmond virginia it has long been
recognized it's waxing poetic about a
confederate statue it has long been
recognized as a beautiful piece of
bronze sculpture to add insult to injury
those who support this taking now plan
to cut it into three pieces and throw
this work of art into storage prior to
its complete desecration
robert e lee is considered by many
generals to be the greatest strategist
of them all now greatest strategist this
is like saying
nazi the german army's nazi strategist
hermann goring was really a good
strategist that doesn't mean we have a
statue for the guy okay
robert e lee is considered by many
generals to be the greatest strategist
of them all president lincoln wanted him
to command the north in which case the
war would have been over in one day
robert e lee instead chose the other
side because of his great love of
virginia
and except for gettysburg would have won
the war he should be remembered as
perhaps the greatest unifying force
after the war was over arden in his
resolve to bring the north and south
together through many means of
reconciliation and imploring his
soldiers to do their duty in becoming
good citizens of this country
um
our culture is being destroyed in our
history and heritage both good and bad
are being extinguished by the radical
left and we can't let that happen if
only we had robert e lee to command our
troops in afghanistan that disaster
would have ended in a complete and total
victory many years ago
what an embarrassment we are suffering
because we don't have the genius
of a robert e lee
this is what the former president of the
united states
has been relegated to
praising
pro-slavery confederate generals
as
geniuses and bemoaning the removal of a
statue now i've said before
i actually don't pay too much attention
to this statue stuff in that i i don't
find it particularly substantive now if
you come to me and you say david sir
do you would you remove the statue yeah
of course i would remove it
or would you rename the middle school
uh away from being named after a
confederate general yeah absolutely
absolutely but for me it's not a big
substantive focus is the point that i'm
trying to make but the bemoaning it as
the greatest loss
also strikes me as completely unhinged
deranged and wacky so there is trump
saying this man was a genius this
pro-slavery general who fought
for uh
who fought for the confederacy
is a genius and the statue is
magnificent then it should remain that's
just horrifying stuff
one of our sponsors is magic spoon
breakfast cereal sweet and tasty like
the cereals i loved as a kid but without
the sugar or the carbs every serving of
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar only
four net carbs 140 calories and packed
with 13 grams of protein perfect if
you're doing keto perfect if you're
doing low carb
great if you're just trying to reduce
your excess sugar intake and because
it's packed with protein it's great
before or after a workout magic spoon
flavors include cocoa fruity frosted
peanut butter blueberry and cinnamon
they're bringing back cookies and cream
they're bringing back maple waffle you
can build your own variety box and try
them all magic spoon is so confident in
the product if you don't love it as much
as i do they will refund your money no
questions asked go to magicspoon.com
pacman the link is underneath this video
and you'll get five dollars off when you
use the promo code pacman at checkout